segunda gran reforma de gabinetes por
parte del gobierno de Boris que se
convierte así en el que cambia más
ministros en su primer año de gobierno
en torno a como bien dices asegurar el
cumplimiento de las necesidades actuales
de los chilenos estas necesidades han
sido esbozadas en su discurso en el que
también se le sintió
la lamentación de que nos fuera aprobada
la reforma tributaria y hizo especial
hincapié en el tema de las pensiones no
podemos permitirnos otro fallo en este
sentido los chilenos no pueden esperar
más esta serían algunas de las
prioridades también relacionadas con la
educación en la que ha mencionado la
importancia de luchar contra el
absentismo escolar y también mejorar la
calidad y la acceso a la infraestructura
educativa además de otros temas como
puede ser reducir la lista de espera
esto además en un discurso marcado
también por los índices de recuperación
económica levemente que se han producido
en este mes en que se redujo un poquito
la inflación uno de los temas que ha
estado en el corazón de los chilenos que
han sufrido fuertemente el alza de
precios por primera vez en tres décadas
de forma muy fuerte en este año y
también los temas de seguridad que
también han sido mencionados por el
presidente en un discurso en el que has
realizado una especie de balance de su
año en el gobierno Patricia y le
preguntó cómo afectan estos cambios a
los equilibrios políticos dentro de la
coalición en el gobierno
pues como bien señalabas los cambios se
hacen buscando más conocimiento es decir
han salido aquellos ministros que tenían
una menor experiencia que eran más
debutantes en el área de la política y
han entrado ministros de Gran tradición
que vienen por ejemplo del ámbito del
bacheletismo de esta forma el gabinete
de borics vira un poco más hacia lo que
es el concertacionismo es decir las
etapas de la concertación que marcaron
la historia política en el país con un
avance de la socialdemocracia en
retroceso de también su propio partido y
su presencia de fuerzas más jóvenes más
nuevas pero que no tienen tanta
experiencia a la hora de tratar temas
tan complejos como los que va que tener
que enfrentar en su segundo año de
gobierno en el que además de remontar
esta reforma tributaria que fue
rechazada y ver que camino toma ahora en
el legislativo puesto que es esencial
para financiar muchas de las reformas
sociales que ansía está también
pendiente la discusión por el tema de
las pensiones en la que borich debería
conseguir un triunfo un aprobar en el
congreso definitivamente